live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
well do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships thank you
for joining us America Dr John deloney
Ramsey personality host of the Dr John
deloney show on a popular podcast on the
Ramsey networks is my co-host today he's
the author of the number one
best-selling book own your past change
your future and the soon to be number
one best-selling book that is in
pre-sale right now building a
non-anxious life we put this out on
pre-sale a couple of weeks ago it is
breaking all kinds of internal records
meaning a whole bunch of you want to
build a non-anxious life and that is a
good thing the book actually comes out
October the 3rd and uh we will let you
buy it now for twenty dollars and we'll
give you seventy five dollars worth of
extra stuff including a talk instant
access to his newest talk smoke fire and
freedom that he did at one of our events
we're going to send that out to you
it'll break down a lot of the lies about
anxiety and help you begin to fight it
so that's 75 worth of free stuff and the
book for all for 20 bucks in other words
we're bribing you to buy it early
uh because it helps John it helps us
with the marketing and the best seller
lists and all that kind of stuff if you
buy it in the pre-sale time thank you
it's if you want to be of help to us you
can do that thank you and you're going
to get a lot of good stuff when you do
it it's fun and it's selling like crazy
John yeah it's a good time it's a good
time very good stuff
let's talk about building a non-anxious
life for a second
we need to
we need to yes let's talk about it
um I mean it's bad out there it's ugly
out there yeah it's um you and I were
recently
um
on another podcast together and we we
talked about we always knew that one guy
who had a nervous breakdown back in the
day like back when we were kids there's
every church or every neighborhood that
one guy it was kind of a mysterious
thing when I was a kid somebody just
kind of disappears for a while yeah and
when you asked what happened well there
was this kind of trauma and there was
this kind of work schedule and there was
this kind of this and just running and
running
and that's the world we've created for
all of us in the 21st century right now
and so I think everybody is running
around trying to whack a mole their
stress and whack them all their their
frustration with their spouse whack them
all their relationship with their kids
and we are their loneliness yeah we're
just dumping gasoline on fire their
financial problems yeah and uh it's just
running in circles the frenetic movement
uh and yet it feels like a rat and a
wheel right it it doesn't feel like it
is a retina wheel it is and we're all on
our own Wheel by ourselves yeah right
and so
um the good news is it can be fixed
that's yeah I wouldn't have written the
book if it was just uh we've got enough
of it's all coming down yeah nonsense
it's burning yeah we've got enough of
that I don't want to participate into
that in that sewage
pit but yeah Dave I really my soul
believe there's a path out and it's in
the the hard part is it's an inexpensive
path and the hard part is it's not a
complicated path it's hard
um but it's not complicated and so
there's not a lot of money in in uh
not super complex cures there's not a
lot of money if I tell you hey what if
you just turn the phone off
um well no you actually got to get the
special app you gotta go do this you
gotta do this you gotta buy this you
gotta go see this doctor what if I told
you just to go meet with friends what if
I told you to go back to church what if
I told you to go move your body and get
out of debt yeah and stop owing people
money
um there's some basic things that our
bodies are trying to get our attention
and that's it's just a call back to
humanity is what this book is yeah six
daily choices that fill your cup back up
that gets drained by the phonetic things
and the empty cup is really where
anxiety comes from right and I had
somebody recently ask me
um hey that seems like like doing this
every day seems like a lot and what I
told them was you can never brush your
teeth so great on Monday that you don't
have to do it again until Thursday every
day you decide I don't have bad breath
and cavity so you brush your teeth twice
a day and we do the same thing with our
exercise we do it you can't tell your
wife once a month you love her or she's
gonna find somebody else that will tell
her on a more regular basis and so
similarly if you want to build an on
anxious life it's a intentional
commitment I'm gonna live this way and
then my body's gonna stop going off the
rails on me every day yeah this is I'm
going completely panic attacks all these
kinds of things they're all anxiety
based Yeah by and large anyway yeah so
and other good news brand new
announcement today regarding the launch
of the building a non-anxious life this
is the first time it's been said in
public right now this thing we're
getting ready to say right now this is
pretty cool I'm excited about this so
the book comes out on October the 3rd
which is a Monday on Wednesday the 5th I
think I've got Thursday Thursday October
15th October 5th is a Thursday okay and
our book comes out October 2nd correct I
got that wrong okay Monday it comes no I
don't know the Tuesday October 3rd there
you go book comes out October 3rd on
Tuesday on the following Thursday
October the 5th here in Nashville at the
brand new Ramsey Event Center Dr John is
going to do a mini uh live event we're
gonna blow it out man on this subject uh
it is him talking on this subject
building a non-anxious life he's going
to talk about some things from the book
and he's going to do an in-depth q a
with the audience as well and you're
going to get a copy of the book when you
buy this yeah so you got a book you'll
be able to you're going to stay inside
I'll stay late to sign every one of them
Sean every book you may have some
musicians pop in and out we'll have a
good time it's gonna be fun gonna be a q
a and a talk at the brand new Ramsay
Event Center on our campus it's a book
launch party that's what we're doing
we're gonna have a big book launch party
for this and so it's 35 bucks including
the book you get the book and we want
you to come party with us yeah it's
gonna be seven o'clock here seven
o'clock in the evening Central Time on
the Ramsey campus at the Ramsey Event
Center please get a ticket and come we'd
love to have you a talk from John live q
a get the book signed get a copy of the
book
tickets start at 35 dollars go to
ramsesolutions.com events
to get yours and um you know spoiler
alert it's all about the book building a
non-anxious life so the talk will be
about building a non-anxious life yes
and the Q a can be whatever you want it
to be uh if you got the guts to ask a
question in front of a room full of
people that's exactly right my wife
might even show up so we'll see we'll
have a good time is she gonna tell
stories about you that she wants us both
to continue to remain employed here at
Ramsey Solutions so I don't think she's
going to do that I don't think she's
gonna do that darn but it is
what do you want people people would pay
double this for deloney dirt oh man she
said hey what I mean the Live Events
team said what do you want people to
feel when they leave and I said I want
them to look at the person they came
with and say what just happened that was
incredible and so that's that's what
we're building up from the floor up it's
gonna be fun oh that'll be fun it's
gonna be okay that's a big call right
there that's a desired future that's
real all right check it out October the
5th the week the book comes out it's a
book launch party with John speaking
doing Q a signing your book it includes
a copy of the book tickets start at 35
dollars
ramseysolutions.com slash events get
your ticket now come to Nashville we'll
have a blast hey or if you're in
Nashville just come on down the road
we'd love to have you anywhere anywhere
around here it's all good this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us netsuite worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com Ramsay
that's netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
day is with us in Washington D.C hi day
how are you
doing well how are you better than I
deserve what's up
um so I'm relatively new to everything
I've been listening to you all since
about March this year and currently
um I'm a brand new mental health
therapist in the area I'm working seven
days a week as a therapist I have over
000 in debt and I feel like I'm
literally drowning in it
yeah because you are right
yeah it's hard keeping my head above
water at this point how did you rack up
200 Grand you go to a private undergrad
and private private grad school
not not even private um
so it's a total of 190 Grand in student
loans
um 5300 uh for One credit card I just
had a hospital bill for 7.50 hit my
account yesterday
and then I have 9 200 left on a car what
do you what's your hourly rate right now
45 per client plus
um I also do some administrative work
for the practice and I babysit on the
weekends are you still working through
licensure 45 is about one-third the
market rate right now
um I'm a brand new like I just graduated
uh grad school she used to work on
you're working on your 3000 hours
yes
what a mess okay
what a mess so what does that mean
you're making a year total household
income now
for 3 000 range this year just because
of um you know I didn't start seeing
clients until March March April
okay
um
and once you get license that will that
your take-home will triple is that right
oh one
oh what if I stay within the practice I
think it'll go up to 65 or 70 an hour
you're not staying in that practice soon
or you're doing your own you're doing
your own clients on the side at full
rate on that back end
yeah I do want to start my own practice
at some point and I'm trying to get as
many pointers by doing administrative
work too sure that's excellent that's
wise
man
so
how long does it take for you to finish
that and get licensed
in March for being licensed for one year
and another paid month the following
March once I get fully licensed done
with all my hours
um but in the meantime I'm trying to
figure out exactly
how I can you know be gazelle intense
without also bringing myself out working
five to seven days a week
Dave hopping here if you think I'm wrong
but I I would consider the phase you're
in
um as an extension of your graduate
school because you can't fully take on
your job until you get that licensure
and you can't get the licensure until
you get those three thousand hours so
really I would look at this as a fourth
year of your graduate degree and you're
getting paid for it
um and so if you're gonna stick to that
I would suggest you cash flow everything
and make sure you're working as many
hours as you can possibly work towards
your license or to get that that thing
out of your head I think you could knock
that out in 18 months if you flipped and
flopped some things around
um the other thing is the decision I
made was I just looked at the dollars
and cents of it all and I ended up
staying working at a university where I
could use the skills I learned with that
graduate degree in counseling towards
another end and it it just paid better
quite honestly and so that may be
something you want to do
um that might be taking a a short-term
the short-term route out when you have
played a long game and want to be a
licensed therapist on the road but man
you've dug yourself quite a hole
yeah so you got yeah you have two
options one is change directions like
John's saying and get your income up uh
or two stay stay the course of what
you're doing and fine tune it to get the
license get the hours in the licensure
as quickly as possible I'm not sure the
firm you're with is going to pay you
market rate it sounds like you're going
to be underpaid off the back end of this
or they're going to bill you out at 125
and they're going to take half of it
of Bill Miata 200 and take over half
yeah yeah if they're billing you out of
200 then you can put yourself out of the
market at 150 and take cash only and you
can do pretty well
okay but that's a couple years away
right you have to have a full book you
gotta have the license to do that yeah
and you got to build a clientele base to
do that so so I'd almost tell me if I'd
almost rather her
Focus Less on trying to pay the debt off
in this madness and more do everything
you can to get every inch of an hour you
can get to get that licensure done but
about the but the hours pay better than
anything else she's doing right it's
better than babysitting it's better than
administrative all day long you know
that's what I mean by fine tuning you
you need to talk to them and say guys
I'm just drowning over here you've got
to give me more billable hours I got to
get these hours behind me can I do a can
I do a two Saturday group therapy
sessions can I do Sunday session instead
of keeping somebody's kids on Saturday
yeah you know that kind of thing so
that's what I mean by fine-tuning it if
you're going to stay the course you need
to fine tune it and jack up the hours
the billable hours and the hours that
are counting towards your licensure so
that we shorten the time frame from two
years down to one or 18 months that kind
of a thing is what I'm thinking about if
you're going to do that then yes John's
right we'll treat this like you're an
intern we'll treat this like you're
doing your uh residency uh for if you're
a medical and you do what you can do
during this time but you don't have the
gazelle intensity towards paying off the
debt because you're not going to move
the needle at fifty thousand dollar
income in Washington DC very much you
can move it but it's not going to move
dramatically but it will move pretty
good if you start making 150 uh you can
start knocking this out real fast
especially if you get used to living on
40. and um and you push that everything
towards this you'll be clear in no time
once you get your hourly rate up and so
if you say all right this is like I'm in
residency until I finish this in the
next 18 months or so then I'm going to
get the rate up and or I'm going to
leave this company and get the rate up
uh way up so that I can attack this very
very aggressively meantime you are
working the desk snowball your student
loans are the biggest one you're not
going to do much towards those you do
the minimum payments you can do for now
just to keep them afloat
and you begin to attack those little
dads the summer 50 medical you need to
clear that you clear the uh little car
loan up maybe over this time you know
you clear up a couple things here and
there
and being intentional will uh if you've
got a game plan where you see a light at
the end of the tunnel even if it's a
three-year light
that lowers the stress level
knowing something's difficult is less
stressful than not knowing what the flip
is going on
ambivalence is much more stressful than
hard things right especially if the hard
things have a Finish Line to them yep
yeah yeah and so you know if I know what
I got to do I can go do it not knowing
is what kills you I think I think it's
an important moment with student loans
about to kick back up
um Dave
let's just say she has her license and
she lives in a community that's very
expensive to live in and the most she's
going to make she's done the market scan
and that's what she's going to make or
I've got colleagues that spend 150 Grand
to go to Duke to get a PhD in history
another one would be history professors
and that job pays 41 000 a year because
there's the Market's so flooded
there is a hard moment when you look at
how much you owe and the thing you
really want to do you've dedicated 10
years five years a lot of your energy
and time to it and it is not going to
pay you enough to pay your bills you can
sit like a bump on a log and yell and
scream and kick and get mad at your
employer all those things Society it
says everybody or you can
grit your teeth and put your mouthpiece
in and go get a job in another field
it's going to pay you 65 000 bucks or
pay you 85 you're gonna have to do
something else at least for a season
till you clean up that hole that you dug
yourself it's nobody else's
um responsibility to clean that up it's
yours
talked to a guy last week he's making
175 000 a year selling cars
you make 38 000 as a social worker with
a master's degree in social work and
have 400 000 in student loan debt but
you may have to go sell cars you may
have to go sell cars and keep that
carrot out there I want to be work
helping kids who are hurting great you
can't afford to do that right now yeah
same as we tell pastors hey right now
you're the kid that's hurting that's
that's exactly right yeah you got to do
what you got to do for a short period of
time that's not a forever thing doesn't
mean you have to abandon your dreams for
your whole life but your dream is turned
into a nightmare so it's time to wake up
right and turn the lights stamp and your
feet is not solving this problem no yeah
I gotta fix it it's not gonna fix it we
are doing the student loan live stream
on September the 12th we'd love to have
you join us it is completely free on
this Jade wash all Ram uh Rachel Cruz
and me will be talking about how we got
here in the student loan mess and where
we're going how to get you out and one
of the things will be just what John
told you spoiler alert so check it out
student loan livestream
ramseysolutions.com student loans
[Music]
thank you
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
[Applause]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Molly is in Boise
Idaho hi Molly welcome to the Ramsay
show
Hi how are you guys better than I
deserve what's up
I really gotta get that t-shirt
um no I'm actually I'm very excited I
talked to you uh your daughter back in
October and to get some advice we just
built a house out here and unfortunately
while we were building it our interest
rate went from 3.8 to 7
ouch so yeah that one hurts so the
mortgage became well outside the day
ruled
way outside so we've decided to sell it
and we are currently under contract and
on the plus side we're going to walk
away with about three hundred thousand
dollars wow wow yeah
so that's where I come to you guys for
advice and this will depend what baby
stuff I will be on after this
conversation which is we're looking to
move to Florida in this community that
seems really great
um so do we pay cash for a town home or
do we take a mortgage of
I think it's about it'll be about eighty
thousand dollars to buy a single family
home that will better suit our needs
what's your household income
um 150
all right well Dave and Sharon Ramsey
don't borrow money for anything ever so
we would not have a choice we would have
to buy a town home and then save up
money and make a move in a couple of
years and move up because that's how we
do everything and have for 30 years
after going broke on this show we don't
yell at you for having a mortgage as you
already are aware uh we we yell at you
for wanting to keep it but but not for
having it okay and so if you took out an
80 000 mortgage that is obviously
something making 150 you could pay off
very quickly that's a very reasonable
approach to what we teach
have you ever lived in Florida before
Molly
okay are you familiar with this area
I am yes in the Bay Area because I all
University of Tampa no you had to get
that in didn't you uh 99 of the time I
would tell somebody moving from Boise
all the way across planet Earth to
Florida
that six months of renting might clarify
this for you
you might find we were actually
considering that first was renting for a
bit that wouldn't hurt because you you
think that this is gonna be perfect for
us maybe it's not and you might find hey
we have a small rent house we could do a
town home it'd be great we think we need
this but we're fine or you might know no
we're gonna kill each other we got to
get out of here
that means you have to move twice which
is the worst on top of the worst I get
that yeah but man I think long term it
might be smart
but mathematically and falling in suit
with what we teach
uh an 80 000 mortgage making 150 and
having a plan to pay that off in four or
five years is that's perfectly fine
okay and also I just want to say Dr John
deloney I have pre-ordered your book the
day that you announced it
I've been thinking my mom was just
hitting refresh so thank you for
confirming that no at least one other
one went to me excellent you're the best
I'm grateful for you thank you Molly
thank you Molly we appreciate that we
have sold more than two so we know it's
not just I think my mom's just sitting
refresh I think she's just burning
through her 401. she's gonna have them
all up in the garage
whenever she passes away we're cleaning
the house tens of thousands of
non-anxious Life books causing your mom
anxiety yes her uh financial planner is
going to tell me I've got two bad news's
for you when she passes you get a whole
bunch of books back and there is no
money
this is your inheritance this is your
inheritance I hope you enjoyed reading
that again
Madison is in Los Angeles hi Madison
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi what's up thank you for taking my
call sure I
wanted to kind of figure out our
finances we both have zero debt um we
own our cars and have about 125
000 sittings in it in a savings account
so we are saving to buy a home we're
currently renting but we are just not
sure what to do
with that money sitting in the savings
account and if we should invest into
some CDs or what your recommendations
for that would be okay
CDs are certificates of deposit it's not
an investment it's just a savings
account
so should you put it in savings or
should you put it in an investment when
are you going to buy
coming down darling yeah I would say
probably
four ish years four or five years would
be our goal why
because then we have enough money to put
a good
your mom found me twenty five thousand
dollars
I know how long you been married
a couple months okay
all right yeah if you're going to let
leave money alone for less than five
years we don't recommend you play that
you put money in mutual funds on the
stock market I would just tell you to
get get a get a CD get a high yield
savings account of some kind uh and you
know try to make this you know there's
some four or five percent stuff floating
around out there right now let's try to
make some of that kind of money that's
not going to make you rich it's just a
fancy parking spot for a really nice car
that's all we're doing it doesn't cost
you anything but it doesn't make you
anything okay and so it's not a good
long-term play but it's a good
short-term play because you're not going
to lose anything and right you can add
to it and you know then buy your home as
soon as possible but don't wait around
in Los Angeles California for prices to
come down if you walk around the streets
of LA you will be hard-pressed to find
anyone that remembers the last time
prices went down
a good percent to put down on a house or
a Home payment well we want you to be
debt free as soon as possible so we like
the 100 Down plan but you're in LA and
so putting down a good strong down
payment on your first home purchase five
or ten percent is fairly normal uh but
where the payment we recommend the
payment not being more than a fourth of
your take-home pay on a 15-year fixed
what's your household income
this year will probably be around 200
000 but my husband is in sale so it's
not
consistent in that sense
and how old are you two
24 and 25. you guys are doing so well
congratulations what does he sell thank
you are you allowed to answer that on
the radio he says meat good oh he's not
going anywhere either no no
California I can see those weirdos
selling oil chemical meat maybe the
plastic exactly yeah so wow that's cool
Madison so yeah a good if you could put
down five or ten percent the best thing
is to put down 20 percent because you
avoid PMI private mortgage insurance
which costs you about 75 dollars a month
per 100 000 borrowed
all right and that doesn't that's not
insurance that gives you anything that's
insurance that pays the mortgage company
and the event you get foreclosed on and
they lose money so you're buying them an
insurance policy because you didn't put
down a big down payment so if you can
put down 20 that is the best of all
worlds on a 15-year fixed on a
conventional mortgage where the payments
no more than a fourth of your take-home
pay
um I think you guys are just getting
started at life and getting started at
this marriage and you're doing really
really well you've got an extremely good
start but it's just causing you some
lack of confidence because you haven't
done this stuff before and that's fine
but I don't think you got a four-year
wait here and I'm going to tell you one
more time prices are not coming down so
if you're waiting on that don't wait but
if you want to wait I want to pile up
some more money and this time next year
by that's certainly not the end of the
world especially the way you guys have
had the ability to save money
congratulations
it's never occurred to me Dave uh
whenever you get married everyone just
you get the the stupidest advice from
all corners of your life everyone's got
an opinion and a thing you need to do
you need to make sure y'all are whatever
and most of the time when you're
newlywed you can't afford anything and
so that that advice rolls off your
shoulder but they're in such a great
position when somebody's saying you got
to buy it right now you got to do this
while driving those cars whatever it can
be real tempting to say okay well I got
to do something with this and now it's
almost the same advice I'd give a
newlywed couple that had nothing which
is just chill yeah work real hard and
chill and don't listen to your broke
friends and your broke family that's
exactly right because they're broke
because of their beliefs and so what
they believe is wrong why is that hard
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
it's a competitive home buying Market
but there's a way you can get an edge
Churchill Mortgage works with you to
understand your budget and your goals
and the Churchill Mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Churchill has
bumped up their seller guarantee to ten
thousand dollars giving your offer the
best chance of being accepted and
helping you win in today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Aaron Is With Us in
Springfield Illinois hi Aaron welcome to
the Ramsay show hi oh my gosh thank you
so much for taking my call I'm
so excited to be talking to you we're
honor honored to speak with you what's
happening
um my husband was unfortunately
diagnosed with brain cancer a year ago
oh man wow um they yeah what kind they
did
um we don't they can't um quite nail
down the cell type but from what they
can tell it's probably slow growing so
we don't have an actual diagnosis at
this point
um but so long story short they did the
surgery this was a successful surgery
removed about 90 of the growth and we
have not had to do any treatments or
anything so far wow and now how's he
doing almost a year ago he's doing so
well good praise God
yes uh he's doing really well um
the part that I'm wondering about
um we're surrounded by just the most
tremendous community
and they um sorry they got together and
did a big benefit for us
and
um they raised a lot of money
um
we however are still in debt so we know
that this money is for his possible
impending treatment
for this cancer if it happens to grow
back which
um
we go for MRIs every three months so
we're kind of in limbo every three
months wondering okay is this when we're
going to do radiation or you know that's
kind of a tough situation
um so my question is we do have this
debt we have about 83 000 in debt total
but the sum of the money
from the benefit from our community is
about a hundred and three thousand
dollars
and right now it's just sitting in our
savings account doing nothing because we
have no idea what we should do it what
is the 83 000 in debt consist of
um we both have student loans
um that's approximately like totals for
the both of us is like 67
000 for that and then we have 16 000 on
one of our cars our other vehicles
already paid off but um so medical is
all cleared up right now
yeah okay insurance insurance and some
other monies have kept you clear of
medical debt so far
so if you if he needs treatment does
Insurance give you similar coverage to
what you've had so far
um I failed to mention he is able to go
back to work he's we're living like
things are fully normal until they're
not on there so that's what you should
do that's that's why
yeah so his um because they are I don't
quite know the coverage of the insurance
I would assume well I mean it cover it
covered brain surgery and you've gotten
out right with no debt
Right medical no medical debt yeah yeah
so you've got good insurance it sounds
like yes yes we do okay and have you
used any money out of pocket how much
money out of pocket to cover co-pays and
non-insurance covered things have you
done
um there's not been much no uh-uh what's
your household
that just would guess about 85 000. okay
well I mean number one let's just say
out loud all of this doesn't matter
compared to what you're already fighting
okay yeah like brain cancer 12 out of
10. right
83 000 worth of debt on a student loan
and whatever uh two out of ten on
importance in life okay so we'll help
you with it I'm not saying we don't need
to work on it but these are not the same
discussions
so you've already won the biggest battle
I hope you ever face in your life
for at least for now you want I don't
know if you won the war but you won the
battle agreed right yeah agreed pretty
incredible so this is this is just them
you know cleaning up the uh the dust on
the Shelf in life it's not much you know
I mean we can get there so uh the more
sure you are
that this is behind you the cancer is
behind you and there's not going to be
needed treatment the more you could use
some of the 103 because the people did
not give you that money only for future
treatment no one wrote a check and said
this is only for future treatment the
people gave you money because they love
you and you're going through hell and
they wanted to be there for you
and they gave you money they did not
have tags attached to it am I missing
something no you're not now I don't want
you to go put the 103 on the 83 right
now just because I want you to have it
until this diagnosis is further in the
rearview mirror
but not because those people in the
community are going to start screaming
well they just paid off their student
loans no they gave you this money
because they loved you and nobody needs
to know anything about your personal
finance you don't have to publish this
in the newspaper
right and you know you know that itchy
feeling you've had for the last six
months that you want to do something and
you can't and you're sitting there with
your husband holding his hand and you
just want to do you want to do I got
something for you
I want you to call the insurance company
and get in writing from them
what they're going to do in case you
have to go get chemo in case you have to
get radiation
okay I want you to become a bulldog and
enjoy it
enjoy the Bulldog enjoy being the
Bulldog enjoy saying no no I need to
know exactly I need you to send me in
writing if they don't send in writing
within 48 hours you're calling them back
saying I need this thing this person at
this time said this keep Exquisite
records and I think you're you're trying
to make decisions without data and man
the more data you can get in this moment
the more peace you're gonna have in your
home
to John's to John's Point let's say
we're six months further down the road
and now this is in your rear view mirror
a good ways agreed
yeah okay and you had conversations with
the insurance company that said we got
you
it's not gonna cost you hardly anything
if he has treatment
those two things those two pieces of
data release some of the 103 for me
to put towards your debt does that make
any sense
yeah but the more unsure we are the more
we need the 103.
right and The Surety will come with
distance in the rear view mirror and
with the data points from the insurance
company that'll give you the sense of
confidence to use some of this without
being unwise and right now you're just a
little bit Paralyzed by the total
freakout you've been through the trauma
you've been through and I don't blame
you I get that so I'm fine not touching
the 103 and let's just chip away at the
student loans for the next six months
just beat on them as hard as you can as
if you didn't have this money
okay and it's not it's sitting there
until we know that we know that we know
that you're not going to need it
okay
um
while it's
sitting you put it in a high yield
savings account make four make four or
five percent so here's the thing hundred
thousand bucks on five percent makes
five thousand dollars a year it makes
two thousand five hundred dollars in six
months that we're talking about two
thousand five hundred dollars does not
enter into the equations we're doing
right now
it's a non-issue
okay okay
25 000 would enter into it but 2 500 is
a it's a it's not relevant it's it's two
percent of the situation we're dealing
with the whole situation not two percent
of it so yeah part just park it in an HS
in a highly yield savings at your local
credit union try to go for it fine four
five six percent something like that
doesn't matter and you and then get the
insurance company's assurance
of insurance
and get this further in your rear view
mirror when was the last how long has he
been out of the hospital and moving
forward
um his surgery is coming up on a year
ago okay so we would be 18 months at
that point and
um you know we don't need to wait five
The Five-Year cancer Mark we don't need
to wait that long but you know if we've
gone 18 months and had almost nothing
happen
um and you got real good
data and in writing from the insurance
company that you're 98 95 90 covered by
them then you use this money and write a
check and you're out of debt and that's
like Christmas we're talking about
that's my Christmas is March now but
yeah but that that's that's where you're
going it's that good point John and if
you get to the end there and you have
five or ten thousand dollars left and
the spirit stares you go find a young
pediatric family of going through kid
cancer give them 10 000 bucks of that
money if you feel so so moved right yeah
nothing wrong with your money that they
gave to you because they love you yep
and you can pay it forward
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you love the
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love
and create actual amazing relationships
Dr John deloney is the expert on that
Dr John deloney show is one of our top
shows on the Ramsay Network he'll help
you with relationships mental health
issues and all kinds of crazy family
stuff yeah and uh life in general and
he's here to help me as my co-host today
he's the author of the number one
bestseller own your past change your
future
and the brand new book that we have
coming out October the 3rd on a Tuesday
I had to clarify that earlier my brain
is locked up called building a
non-anxious life and uh in a world field
filled with anxiousness anxiety building
a non-anxious life how do you keep your
cup full to deal with the stuff that
comes at us in the world we live in
today that's all coming out you can
pre-order the book right now at
ramseysolutions.com phone number here to
talk is triple eight eight two five five
two two five that's completely free
Alan's with us in Cleveland Ohio hi Alan
how are you
I'm doing better than I deserve it's an
honor to speak to my mentor I'm on I'm
honored to speak with you sir how can I
help
you know uh I've seen countless of your
videos and and online calculators of how
much house you can afford
of these mortgage principle of interest
and whatnot how much house can you
afford if you're paying cash
something happened
away what happened to your phone yeah is
that better yeah that's much better
thank you yeah you sound like you're
trying to discuss your voice here for a
second all right okay you got the money
to pay cash how much money you want to
pay for a house
500 000. okay what's your net worth
1.6 million that's fine
it's good that's cash that's cash I have
a 200 000 paid off house now okay I got
no problem with that all right here's
the way I look at that all right having
studied wealthy people for years and
you've obviously done very well okay the
smaller your net worth
the higher the percentage of your net
worth your home is going to be
if you have a 500 000 net worth and a
250 000 house that wouldn't be unusual
at all
right
okay but if you have a 10 million dollar
net worth and a nine million dollar
house that's weird
okay you agreed okay so the larger your
net worth the smaller the portion of it
would go to your home
okay
my home is a very small percentage of My
overall net worth
but I'm blessed I'm sitting in a
building that's worth you know somewhere
around 400 million and so if I had a
home that was worth you know the 200
million that'd be weird you know it just
wouldn't make any sense at all it'd be
very strange to live in by the way but
yeah man weird didn't even touch that
but yeah but anyway the uh you see what
I'm saying so but yours is about a third
of your very successful 1.6 million
dollar net worth congratulations that's
not out of hand if you told me 1.3 I'd
be freaking out a little bit do you see
what I'm saying
well my current house is worth two
hundred thousand so I'm actually going
to be you know I'll still have the 1.2
roughly yeah yeah but are you going to
keep the current house
no okay so you're still the portion of
your personal residence is 500 000 am I
right
if I buy the 500 000 house and you pay
cash for it it'll cost me three right
now sell this for two yeah but your net
worth stays the same
you just shifted it around yes
correct yeah it's just the percentage of
your net worth that goes to your home
went up from I don't know 250 as a
percentage of 1.6 to 500 as a percentage
of 1.6 which is roughly one-third right
and so that's okay that doesn't bother
me a bit but if you told me 1.5 of my
1.6 is going to be in my house I would
say tell your wife no
no
I am retired I am retired on a 74 000 a
year income okay doesn't matter
doesn't matter because this is a net
worth thing you can afford the house why
why why why don't you want to buy it
still here I've been living the Dave
Ramsey life a long time worked very very
hard for my money I'm 68 years old uh
live like no one else the Dave Ramsey
life has the rest of that sentence
what's the rest of that sentence you
live like no one else so that
you can live and give like no one else
late in life and why not this is the
part where you get to enjoy the fact
that you've done a really good job and
you're reasonably wisely enjoying it
and you should
you know I can say this kid's a little
scared it's such a big I'm in a 200 000
house now you get a little scared it's a
bigger home it's more maintenance more
property tax it is but it's not going to
break you
right I'll never run out of money what
it is more than anything else is it's
emotional because it feels weird because
your brain is completely comfortable
with 250 and you're doubling what your
brain's comfortable with and I think you
have identified those people by 500 000
other houses guys like me don't do that
exactly exactly I I I don't buy it you
know I'm ready to add 1.5 million before
I buy a two Big Macs once again yeah buy
one well the coupon you know hey what'd
you do for a living Alan when you were
in your career eating air conditioning
not a lot of work for a contract and how
much of this 1.6 million did you inherit
85 000 house
how long ago
oh
1991. okay all right so that did help
yeah that's good wow you're very
impressive very very well done your
classic baby steps millionaire very well
done I'm going to send you a copy of
that book I want you to read it I think
you'll enjoy it because it's about you
he's also classic hey did I miss an HVAC
guy I don't live in that guys like us
don't live over in that neighborhood and
it's a tough transition to realize
that's one of the reasons I I
um I I put that saying out there live
like no one else so that later you can
live and give like no one else because
we don't want you to be tightwatched for
the purpose of being a tightwad right we
don't want you to be careful with your
budgeting just for the purpose of being
here we want you so that you get to have
a wonderful life so that you change your
family tree so that you can be
outrageously generous and find a uh you
know a widow that you and I took the
call on the air the other day and a
everyday millionaire a babysitters
millionaire heard the call and called
and called up her house okay in the wild
and it was five thousand bucks and he
wrote checking think about it so but you
don't have to think about that when
you've got 1.6 and and that that's the
reason but then if if you start say I'm
gonna play small ball just for the
purpose of playing small ball no I'm
gonna play small ball so I never have to
again right I'm gonna drive a piece of
crap car so I never have to again the
car I drove over here today and piece of
crap but I have driven some crap okay
but I drove I drove like no one else so
now by God I drive whatever I want I
drive like no one else you know and you
know somebody's left us don't like that
oh well Tuffy's you know I ain't
plugging it in either I'll just tell you
that
so you know it's you see what I'm saying
I mean live like no one else so later
you can live like no one else that's
right that's right they and give like
there's a reason for this you got to
play it you gotta now and I'm so proud
of you man congratulations you're
awesome yeah you you know I want you to
learn to flex the muscle to enjoy it
some of this money more than you have
been it's time it's your time and I want
you to be outrageously generous too dude
this is their Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
things backed by their
100 percent satisfaction guarantee and
shipping always free see whyblinds.com
is the number one online retailer of
custom window coverings go to blinds.com
now and save 50 off selected products
visit blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
thank you
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
hey we want you to go to
ramsaysolutions.com events and uh sign
up he is doing a launch party for his
book non-anxious building a non-anxious
life go to ramsesolutions.com events it
is 35 including the book we're going to
do that on October the 5th the book
launch week at the Ramsey Event Center
and it's brand new you're going to love
it if you haven't seen the inside of
this thing it is amazing and he'll be
doing a talk about building a
non-anctions like taking your questions
on a q a signing every single person's
book that's there and of course seating
is limited it is a building it only
holds so many people so if you want to
come it's 35 bucks go to building or go
go to
ramsaysolutions.com
events and get signed up for this it's
the launch party
another launch party we're doing is uh
September the 15th on a Saturday and a
Friday evening before that we're doing
the smart conference in the North
Chicago area uh up around we're gonna be
in Willow Creek Church and uh doing an
event there called the smart conference
John Dr John deloney Rachel Cruz George
Campbell Jade washaw Ken Coleman Dave
Ramsey we're gonna be talking about
career mental health and money all
evening and all the next day you're
going to leave there being smart check
out the tickets September 15 and 16 at
ramseysolutions.com events there's a few
left we'd still like to have you we only
do a couple of those a year mark Is With
Us in Springfield Missouri hey Mark
welcome to the Ramsay show
Mr Ramsey and Dr galoney uh this is just
calling to uh ask you guys I own kind of
it's my job but uh I I own a business
but I only employ me and
um I'm trying to figure out that's
awfully nice of you Mark I'm in the
middle of my uh the baby steps all like
a quarter of the way into it
um I've got 40 000 of a hundred and
twenty thousand paid off and I was
wondering with the business income
um should that be put into the business
first like I've once I get my my tax
account full then should I build up an
emergency fund for the business or
should I focus that on
the baby steps
what do you do
I'm a pooper scooper
okay and
um what are you making
uh with combined household income with
money on the business on the business oh
just the business it's about a hundred
thousand okay and
um
we'll just stop right there for a second
first thing ran through my mind is
that's a lot of poop okay
which is one of the the internal slogans
about this show but listen
listen
if you are listening to this show and
you say I can't get ahead and I can't
figure it out there's no jobs Mark is
making 100K as a pooper scooper so let's
just keep that out picking up the dog
Pretty stinking good okay all right Mark
uh all the all the puns aside you've
done them all too so you've been doing
this a while yeah yeah all right so it's
it's that's amazing I'm so proud of you
I have no idea but um
just you and you have like a route I
assume you go to certain locations and
people pay you to come to their location
correct
yes okay cool and uh and how often do
they pay you
uh I some some people pay me weekly some
people pay me monthly so it's just okay
uh all right that's fine and um do you
have a separate business account
yes and all the money that they pay you
goes into that account never goes direct
to your personal account correct
correct great first move when you pull
money out of the business account to
bring some home you should always set
aside one-fourth for taxes you alluded
to that sounds like you've heard me tell
you to do this before
yeah well I've I've listened to your
show for quite a while okay so you're
setting us out of fourth when you take
it home you take a thousand dollars out
of the account you said 250 for taxes
put 750 in your personal account correct
yes okay good that's a good plan and you
said household income so your wife is
working what does she make
uh
uh so she makes I think 50 and then I've
got military retirement and we're foster
parents so we get a stipend for that and
that's how much total we get about 170
a year so another 20 in military
retirement in Foster stipend yes okay
cool all right good and what are the
expenses of running this type of
business fuel I assume to go to the
locations yeah there's there's fuel
advertising uh when trash bags yeah and
Febreze every once in a while I have to
replace a raker uh bucket yeah but it's
not much yeah so no so out of the 100
um I mean your your expenses are 10
grand maybe right
be uh probably somewhere around there
maybe maybe 15. yeah okay so the vast
majority of this comes home
yes why would you need a business
emergency fund at this stage
uh for replacing Parts on the vehicle or
you know stuff like that yeah okay
do you have a separate work vehicle from
your home vehicle
yes
okay so there's like a truck involved or
something
yeah minivan but yeah okay all right
cool all right
uh
this is so great
um Mark I gotta tell you you've made my
entire week
this is so just thinking about you
cruising Springfield in a minivan just
getting out with a shovel and some
headphones on making a hundred thousand
dollars a year just it restores my faith
in humanity you know it's just a marker
all right so uh and you couldn't do that
if it was Russia I'll just say all right
so the um there's no no Great Danes in
Russia yeah that's it so all right
um
I don't think you need much of an
emergency fund right now I think I would
take most of this home of the 85 000
home uh or or let's just call it all
right let's put something in in the
return so what we would do in the entree
leadership is we would say take your net
profit which in is 85 cents on the
dollar okay so if we make ten thousand
dollars this month we're going to take 8
500 and call that net profit
all right and uh we would apply a
formula to that and say x percentage
goes home and the rest goes into an
emergency fund
okay our retained earnings Fund in your
case I think 10 percent would be more
than adequate
and then take the rest home
into the retain earnings so my model
formula you make you make ten thousand
dollars this month it's a big month it's
a good month you have 8 500 we're going
to call that profit we're you know or
let's call it eight thousand dollar
profit we're going to leave the rest of
it in there for expenses that's one
thing and then we're going to set aside
ten percent of that eight thousand so
eight hundred dollars goes in another
account for retained earnings and we're
going to take seven thousand two hundred
dollars home I just made a formula up
but you can do something like that to
where you take the most of this home and
you leave a little bit in the business
and you cover expenses and the actual
expenses in the business that month
okay and does it change any if I were to
hire somebody like I I would have to set
up a fund for that as like in case I
don't have the money to cover a paycheck
or something correct
uh at that scale they should be getting
paid off the job not off the paycheck
right yeah yeah you're not and you're
not and you're not going to hire them to
make enough that it's going to impact
you that much anyway you shouldn't on
the business success so yeah
um and and you would increase your
income associated with them so no I mean
maybe a little bit but it wouldn't
change substantially I until you get
this uh last 80 000 at home paid off I
want to take most of this money home
other than tax money and business
expenses
okay gotcha all right I appreciate it
all of it but not all of it but most of
it and man
and and hey you know like a guy like
that is like he's heard all the jokes
over and over all the bad 13 year olds
he laughs all the way to the bank yeah
and it's just but it you know I can't
imagine what the decal on his uh the the
wrap on his on his van says right or
when all of his military buddies get
together and they just go around I mean
there's some great these guys that do
pooper scooper they got great names out
there that are hilarious I mean if
there's some fabulous names I remember a
teacher during covet who paid off like
100 Grand because she would she was
teaching and she was driving and
delivering and I remember thinking oh
she's one of those curve Busters that
takes everybody's excuses away Mark goes
into that camp 100 000 bucks collecting
dog Cha-Cha down his neighborhood not a
boy man wow there's no more excuses left
you gotta love it serious mic drop this
is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with why
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump sum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
Dr John deloney Ramsay personality is my
co-host hi Brittany welcome to the
Ramsey Show
Hi how are you better than I deserve
what's up
um me and my husband were wanting to
call in we um we obviously have debt we
have a mortgage
um
and some other things like an SBA loan
for the business
equipment loans but we recently had a
baby in July and he was born with most
of his he has like one percent of his
small intestine left which leads him to
be life dependent on tpn IV nutrition
he'll eventually long-term need a
transplant for his small intestine for
sure of we don't know about the other
organs
but our question is do we stop
um saving we have an emergency fund do
we stop paying off our debt in stockpile
for what's to come we know that it's
going to be very expensive but we're not
sure to what extent like Medicaid
insurance will help cover so we were
just kind of wanting your advice on that
what do we do for long term because for
the transport we'll have to relocate
things like that so it's going to be
very expensive
how you doing
okay
that's pretty pretty rough thing how
many babies have you got
we have two boys and my other baby I had
early but nothing was wrong with him but
with Benjamin it was kind of a shock to
us
um that it was that it was so so much
was dead
um
but he's he's had two surgeries so far
and they both went well he has a central
line he'll he'll have food through like
a bag IV nutrition
and um until he can get a transplant
which could be you know as little as one
or up to you know teenage years the
older they are the better the success
okay yes sir
all right how much I'll show you the
only debts you have left are SBA and
mortgage
they won't
know exactly what we have
um 188 K is on our mortgage we have
um 15 on car payments and work equipment
um and then we have the SBA loan that
was 50 000.
um so all together we have about two
what's your household income
he brings in about 50k a year but he has
two to three thousand that's retained
saving retained earnings
but he keeps that held back but about a
year it's about 50k or so
and I stay home with the boys okay
um
well the the
baby's one month old right
a little over yes sir
um so it's going to be some years but we
just want to know like should we only
pay so much towards debt or kind of stop
or just do like the biggest things first
yeah what would be your advice number
one we
take care of Benjamin before we do
anything before we worry about anything
okay now now we've got to Define then
what and you've been helping me to find
that teaching me for the last few
minutes what take care of Benjamin means
okay it could mean you don't need and it
does mean you don't need any money for a
year
okay right because you said he would be
one year at the earliest before they
possibly did this correct
yes sir you have they have to tell
children with short have to be at least
a year right and it depends on how like
that some kids do really well with IV
nutrition you know they've been here a
long time with that yeah but I'm saying
that the earliest is one year uh unless
other complications pop up and you would
need money for those
yes sir the the complications come from
a central line risk of infection we're
one whole month into this
yes sir yes sir he's already had a
second surgery he shouldn't have any
more unless problems arise right now
it's just getting him to grow learning
how to take care of him bringing him
bringing him home and when he comes home
he'll have Home Nurses for as long as he
needs the care but in our in our minds
we were like wow this is going to be
something that you know we're gonna need
at least
from what we read that's over like two
hundred thousand dollars things like
that first transplants who's paying for
the nurses
um right now of course when they're born
they have their the um the Medicaid or
the peach state so he's on that in the
hospital that will cover for his first
year
um there was a mention that because he
had so much of a resection that he could
possibly qualify for Social Security
um disability for if you have more than
50 percent you qualify for that okay
um but we're just we're really not sure
sure what it's gonna what does your
husband do for a living
he does landscaping and hardscaping
um
because as I'm hearing
it's almost sounds disassociative how
you're able to talk and the way you are
right now it's almost like you're the
doc not the mom yeah like you've created
a space because you had to and I'm not
with you maybe you're just so much
tougher than me I mean I
I
hard
but I also feel like I have to somewhat
be
I have to make sure that I'm learning
everything and trying to retain
everything
I get I have to put a short part of it
for how I'm feeling maybe
I need you to make sure yeah you do
you're you're a mom in a crisis and
you're you're making sure the stuff gets
done and that's that's Noble I want you
to make sure you've got um one or two
girlfriends that you can just go have
coffee with once a week and just tell
the truth too okay
I he's not on the phone but if I was to
talk to a husband in this situation he
had called me I would tell him I know
you love what you do but you're gonna
have to find a way to earn some more
money
and you have to stop taking out fifty
thousand dollar loans for a fifty
thousand dollar job on your on your
small business you have to figure
something else out and it may be going
to work for the man for somebody and
maybe getting two jobs working for other
people but he needs to make some more
money
y'all just seeing your future staring
you down and choosing to ignore that
reality that this is coming
um is gonna and we're hoping that you
know qualify for this maybe get this
that's that's a tough road to hoe and
yes sir he's got to make some hard
choices about yeah I need to go do
something else
okay yes sir oh and or add something to
the equation as if he wasn't already
working hard because he is
yeah he's we're not saying he's a bad
guy that's right no I think he's a great
guy I just think question but I think
reality changed everybody's Direction
forty seven thousand is going to make
this really tough
let's make it really tough
the math is really hard on that so in
the meantime while he's considering that
and we're doing anything we can do to
get some extra income into this house to
add to this equation I would do nothing
on the debt I would just pile up cash
let's do that until uh until after the
first of the year
and let's get let's hit Benjamin's six
month birthday anyway and and have a
little bit of a track record on all of
these different very medical variables
that are moving in different directions
at all times
um and if if things are
still progressing exactly like you
currently think they're going to by
January and you had you know some money
saved up you may want to start talking
about paying off the car and paying off
the little debt the SBA and the house
I'm not worried about they can just sit
there as long as you pay the minimums on
them until we get Benjamin squared away
but I'd love as you're fighting for for
him with your wallet I'd love to not
have the car in the equipment loan you
see what I'm saying
yes sir but I don't want to do that
today today I just want you to have some
money just stack some cash because
Benjamin needs um
some margin some money margin between uh
him and whatever he's facing
yes sir
because you know paying to stay
somewhere else
things like that yeah if you haven't
done this already go get yourself a
binder and maybe spend a couple extra
bucks and get a nice one
and get some dividers and begin to keep
all of this in a centralized place but
and particularly the questions you don't
have answers to yet
where are those three places what are
some real estate things you can look at
because you're going to pop your head up
in the middle of the night not be able
to sleep and you'll be able to oh I've
already got those questions written down
I can just go in order
and it's a way of keeping this Chaos
Control what I can control I'm going to
keep it right here in the spider and
every time I have a question about how
much does formula cost this IV stuff
cost how much does this cost how long
does the nurse is going to keep coming
when does Medicaid cut off I'm going to
write all those those things down I'm
gonna make it my my day job in addition
to taking care of these boys getting
some answers to these things and keeping
it all in one centralized place and
Brittany
um you call us here
anytime you got a question we want to
help we got you we want to help we
understand and um we'll be praying for
Mr Benjamin this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five thank
you for joining us Evan is in Lexington
Kentucky hi Evan welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hey Dave good to talk to you
good to talk to you how can I help
so some context about our situation I'm
a medical student
my wife's an enrollment counselor at a
university she brings in thirty seven
thousand dollars
um she does that but she's got four
bachelor's degrees and they're on
different areas of Christian Ministry
um and so we just got signed up on every
dollar and all that stuff but we're
trying to figure out
um even with like living well below our
means we're still kind of going a little
bit about our budget so we're trying to
figure out should she seek a higher job
uh should I do the terrible thing of
taking out a little bit more student
loans or or what do you think
uh you're suggesting taking out student
loans to live on
um yeah because I'm not able to work
they're in school yeah it's not it's by
far not the the primary thing we want to
do yeah
you know so that's not even on the table
that's just straight up dumb
um she's got four bachelor's degrees why
is she not making more money
um honestly we live in a low income area
uh they're in Christian Ministry and
people don't want to pay and she kind of
has to work from home right now because
she's been dealing with uh some chronic
pain
how old is she
uh she's 23. what kind of chronic pain
does a 23 year old have
I mean that's a good question we've seen
every kind of doctor and they're still
trying to figure that out we're paying
on a three thousand dollar MRI the
insurance wouldn't cover and all that
stuff so she doesn't really know she's
in physical therapy but beyond that they
didn't really tell us anything
and how did she manage four different
um bachelor's degrees in the same
place
yeah so a lot of the degrees had
overlaps with the courses so she was
able to take a lot of different like
kind of expand out spend about four and
a half years and yeah I got them all
knocked out together so I'm just gonna
say this I don't want to project my
world onto hers but as a guy who
couldn't quit going to school
it was a a harsh stop in front of the
mirror
that finally said what are you running
from what are you what are you trying to
chase
right because I got a whole bunch of
degrees too and it looks cool on paper
but actually the dark secret behind it
was I was running and running and
running trying to prove to everybody
that I had some sort of value or she's
not in school no she's out but that same
attitude goes into your professional
World it goes into your I can't do this
kind of thing there's a lot going on
here is that right
uh yeah she honestly she wasn't a
Christian and she got saved and she
wanted to go learn about God in college
so she just took all the Christian
classes she could and she really didn't
go because she eventually looking for a
job or she you know at the time what are
her four degrees what are they in
um they're in Christian Studies which is
like scholarship and text criticism by
the Bible and youth family ministry
um
and then like it's like family
administrative in general and then just
a missions and degrees well
okay all right there are some sizable
churches in the Lexington and Louisville
markets
that could use an administrative person
that has this level of knowledge and
it's worth double thirty seven thousand
dollars
okay so here's the thing that can happen
in an arc like you're with and um I've
been functioning in the Christian
Community uh for
40 years now
um and uh sometimes what can happen is
is that we say uh that in order to in
our minds somewhere deep down inside in
order to serve God we have to make no
money
right and um that is not in the Bible
um and you don't you know I in order for
it to be holy I have to take the skill
set that I have and make half of what I
can make somewhere else by working at a
non-profit and then I get to call it
holy or working at a Ministry and then I
get to call it holy uh the the holy work
is when you are doing something as unto
the Lord do your work Colossians 3 22 as
unto God heartily as unto God when you
do it with excellence and your your work
your service to your employer Your
Excellence is your ministry is your
worship
um not necessarily exactly what is
happening inside the building that you
work at now we're blessed at Ramsey and
that we get to do actual Ministry and uh
and in a for-profit setting and pay
people more than market rate to work
here the most excellent people on the
planet and so uh you know we've got we
got the whole enchilada but we had to
work through that emotionally and
spiritually to make that okay before we
could go do it
um so I I don't know if she's struggling
with and I don't know how this impacts
the medical situation or the medical
situation impacts this which one's the
tail and which one's the dog but uh this
idea that
um because I met Jesus and radically got
saved and I went and saved a bunch of
Christian stuff I am doing my best for
God by making no money while we're
talking about taking out a student loan
while you're studying medicine is just
not that is not a true statement so yes
she should go make more money and yes if
she has to go to an office to do that
and if she can handle the pain of doing
that physically she should go to an
office and go make seventy or eighty
thousand dollars she should do that for
her regardless of your medical career
right and you can also get degrees in
Theology and go work at a marketing
agency or at a police station you can
work all over the place with those
degrees as well you're not limited to
just doing Ministry stuff
okay because she's she's willing to step
out of the mold to do that she hey
considered she's going to start her
Master's in counseling no no no she does
not need a master's account she's
addicted to education yeah she's
addicted to pushing reality down the
street in your talk this is the pot
talking to the kettle here man
there has there has to be some peace
inside her own heart inside her own home
and you're not going to find it at the
University
getting a degree it's not there so going
to the marketplace and love people well
serve people well somehow go do
something with Excellence go do
something with a Gusto and make a pile
of money doing it just like you're gonna
do like you're gonna be a doc and do
that as a person of Faith do that with
gusto my doc is a person of faith I
don't I'd rather not have a doc it's not
and so you know you get to do that from
medical school and there's you know
there's no reason there's no rule that
says you're not allowed to make money in
this process
um it's just not there it's not there
that's a a toxic version of Christianity
that's gotten woven into too many
people's minds and so um yeah we've just
gotta we gotta break this I I think it's
best for
I I will put out an idea and I do not
know the nature of her medical condition
and I am not a medical professional but
having done what I do a long time I will
put out an idea that were she in
something where she was making a pile of
money and extremely fulfilled I would
uh think you might see a reduction in
pain and you have great human connection
it's it's it's you're exactly right
you're exactly right sometimes chronic
pain is your body telling you we got to
change this environment that's your
direction and it's Harding to another
degree retreating and working only from
home might not be the best it might Stir
It Up yeah it might be making it very
tough yeah I'm not saying we don't know
that but there's a possibility that
that's in there right yeah that this
sounds like it started there's a pattern
developing in this conversation here so
uh happiness is somewhere over there
after I cross that finish line on that
finish line and I'm going to say this to
my colleagues my former colleagues
shame on you guys for accepting somebody
through a program four different
bachelor's degrees out of the same
Department with the same classes with
the same professors taking more money
and more money and more money
I was blessed Dave to have a teacher
because I try to do that too in my
undergrad and they said no no you
complete this and then you go on to
graduate school if that's what you want
to do
but I needed some wisdom there and this
institution sounds like they just kept
taking her money and kept taking her
money and kept taking her money and for
what you're gonna go to a church and be
like well you got a degree in Christian
Studies and you got to agree in
Christian Ministry but man you should
have got that degree and Christian
something or other so we can't you can't
work here that's not how that works
shame on that school yeah
[Music]
all right that puts this hour of the
Ramsay show in the books
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
laughs
foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships thank you
for joining us open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five Dr John deloney Ramsey
personality host of the book own host of
the book author of the book the number
one best-selling book own your past
change your future and the brand new
book building a non-anxious life which
is on pre-sale now all of those things
and host of the Dr John deloney show on
the Ramsay networks he's my co-host
today thanks for hanging out James is
with us James is in Orlando hi James how
are you
hey how you doing thank you so much for
having me on sure man what's up
so I'm having trouble getting to pay off
my debt I've tried many different things
make budget apps different things like
that and I've just come to the
realization over the past few days
actually that I'm just not I I lack the
discipline and it really needed to stop
living paycheck to paycheck and the
saddest part is I have a really good
salary what's your really good salary
um I make 170. oh that's impressive okay
how much of that do you have sir
uh collectively I have 27 27 28 000 what
kind of woke me up on this is I ignored
my debt for years
um and then one of my both of my credit
cards were canceled and I settled one of
them and that was fine and then the
other one I honestly completely forgot
about until a few days ago when I
received a I was served because they're
suing me for the debt and that kind of
woke me up where I said I need to stop
pushing things I think I kept pushing
things forever because I said well you
know I have a good amount of money
coming and you know my next paycheck and
I'll deal with it then but yeah how long
you've been making 170 James
just for about six months what were you
making before that
okay I
have for about a year during covid which
really hit me hard and so during that I
was doing Uber and making you know about
20 000 a year before that I was making
90.
what do you do
I work in politics
okay Consulting okay
so is that cyclical does that go away in
another
nine months
no um I I this will be my salary at
least for the next few years
um I don't anticipate a changing or
changing jobs be some things to keep in
mind too I have to have two places to
live because my job commutes a lot
between here and Orlando and in New York
City some of my uh colleagues that I
work with do hotels
um but most people just end up having
two places of residence so do you have
currently or two places of residence
yes
and how much is the New York apartment
the New York apartment is
um two thousand how much is the Orlando
apartment
um 1200
um but my my girlfriend uh and I split
it so okay so so this is uh sorry the
1200 is what I pay in my split
okay so this is forty thousand dollars
so so basically you've been spending
somewhere
all of your money for the last six
months
which is eighty five thousand dollars
it's other than some rent is unaccounted
for
yeah so you're spending your money James
so it's a combination of me living
beyond my means yeah and also yeah it's
a combination of that but also there's
some key different things that I just
don't have that I think so for instance
I don't have a car I do need to get a
car and instead of because you know I've
been my credit isn't exactly I've been
worried about where is eighty thousand
dollars gone in six months it's starting
to sound like Congress
it's me it's me it's I've been renting
cars a lot
um instead of buying I my girlfriend's
out of work so I've been covering a lot
of her expenses and then I'm living
beyond so the whole thing I'm splitting
the rent was bull crap
she does that but beyond that but beyond
that I've been covering a lot of things
so it's I definitely need to get my
stuff together the other thing to keep
okay here's what I do in these
situations and I I have to set a new set
of things instead of going I'm
just not good at this I've not got any
discipline I and you keep naming off all
these things that you are that you
actually aren't it's just what you do
um it's not your actual identity uh so
what I decided a year of years ago I had
the blessing of going completely
bankrupt and losing everything so I
didn't have a choice
I was in an extreme situation the only
way I could eat would was to behave
the only way my children had a warm home
was to behave I didn't have a choice and
so what I've done with folks like you
over the years is I want you to put
yourself mentally in a space as if you
don't have a choice let's just pretend
this okay let's pretend that you go to
the doctor this afternoon and he says
you need twenty seven thousand dollars
by Christmas
or you're gonna die
all of a sudden James you would be a
person of discipline
all of a sudden your budget would be
perfect all of a sudden your stupid
decisions would go away because you
would have one goal I want to live I
want 27 000 by December and suddenly all
of this bull crap that's running around
in your head would could become laser
focused and you'd be going 27 000 James
got one goal stay alive get twenty seven
thousand dollars no other goal matters
no other crap matters my colleagues have
two apartments who gives a crap what
your colleagues do you are a broke guy
making 170 you gotta change some crap
really this has got you gotta you gotta
get up in your face man get up in your
own Grill and go that's enough I've had
it I am this is crazy I'm ashamed I'm
disgusted with how this looks and how
this feels because that's what you've
been telling me
and I'm I'm so disgusted that I'm gonna
change it
and if you get sick and tired of being
sick and tired James that's when you
change your life
yeah because you you know stupid people
don't make 170 Grand a year
they don't they don't even get hired
okay you couldn't even have gotten the
job if you're stupid so you're not
stupid
but buddy you've been doing some stupid
stuff hadn't you
yeah so stop it for real
just pretend you need 27 000 by
Christmas or you're gonna die
and all of a sudden I'm not renting any
cars I'm gonna go get me a four thousand
dollar car and put it down here in the
driveway or I'm gonna Uber somewhere and
I'm gonna Uber I'm not renting anymore
I'm gonna quit we are not going out to
eat and hey uh chick you need to get a
job or you need to move out because I'm
getting rid of this two thousand four
hundred dollar apartment for two broke
people if you don't and oh by the way
I'm getting out of this New York lease
for sure and we're gonna run a cheap
stinking Hotel over across the river and
haul your little butt over the Staten
Island Ferry over there and get to work
and you know you don't have to spend
that kind of money to work in New York
um because you got to change some stuff
man that that if I'm you that's what I'm
doing but you got you got to turn this
disgust into Behavior change the shame
in the behavior change this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
thanks for joining us America Dr John
deloney Ramsey personality is my co-host
today we appreciate you being here hey
folks if you like what you're hearing we
would appreciate you subscribing to the
show or click the follow button you can
also share the show share a link uh if
your particular methodology has a share
button use that or you can just tell
people about that's sharing it right so
spread the word we know you are because
our ratings and our listenership and our
rankings with I
phones or iTunes and apple and all that
stuff they continue to go up and iPhones
and iTunes it's none of that it's Apple
it's literally the oldest sentence I've
heard it's just like that was the worst
possible dinosaur recognition with
Blockbuster yeah you go to run yourself
down to Blockbuster get yourself a VHS
get yourself a tape get yourself a tape
let's do the question of the day just do
that praise God today's question of the
day is sponsored by neighborly your hub
for Home Services is your to-do list too
long whether it's a simple repair or a
whole list of Home Improvements Mr
handyman's experienced professionals are
here to make your home work for you
visit neighborly.com to find expert home
service providers including a locally
operated Mr Handyman near you all right
today's question comes from Kyle in
Minnesota Kyle writes I'm 34. I've been
married for five years and I have two
children under three so basically he's
living in a blender with the top off for
the first time in our lives together we
are debt free my wife is very frugal
woman a very frugal wonderful woman had
to make sure you got that in there and
it's been very patient with me as I've
worked through debt that I have brought
into the marriage we just sold our home
to take advantage of the market and are
currently renting again from the sale of
our home we paid off 20 grand in high
interest credit card debt we put an
emergency fund away and we have the
money to put away a six a three six
month fund after this we have thirty
thousand dollars left over which is an
incredible feeling but I'm scared to
even have it available I don't want to
screw this up I just know that thirty
thousand dollars can disappear pretty
quick if I'm not responsible I'm
wondering if we should lock up this
money in a CD or should I take
um or should I take the route to face
the things in me that would make me be
irresponsible for the first time in a
long time I have the burden of debt off
me completely and I want to keep it that
way what's your advice for some changes
I can make to actually become a
responsible person and not have to lock
my money down into a bank to watch over
it for me
that's a long question there
um
very self-aware yeah very self-aware and
I like I mean I think his approach is
actually right because a lot of folks
run into a
um into this kind of situation and they
instantly go to shame they go to
character issues they go to I'm a
failure and this guy is looking at it
which I think is in the right way which
is all right there's a set of skills I
don't have and so I'm going to begin to
to seek out these skills and begin to
practice it that's good for you Kyle
that's awesome that's very good and so
what I know about myself is when I get
emotional
and it sounds like money is something
that spins your body up makes you
emotional so when I get emotional I
bring other people into that
conversation because
I know one thing about deloney and
that's when he gets emotional uh he gets
irrational and he does dumb stuff and so
I will bring one or two friends in I
happen to sit by Dave and ask him
questions regularly I have a banker that
I'm close to that I'm friends with that
I can run stuff by so I make sure I've
got people in my life as I'm learning a
new set of skills the other thing I do
is I'm uh Dave I we've talked about this
on the show a lot
you set a new identity I'm a guy that
stewards his money well for himself and
his family that's who I am and I'm going
to reverse engineer a set of skills a
set of behaviors that's going to back
that up I do not spend money out of this
account this is going to be your house
fund by the way I do not spend money out
of the house fund I don't that's just
who I am and if that means don't carry
your debit card great that means fill in
the blank while you're learning great
but that I'm Dave that's that those
that's the path I'm gonna take yeah
you're exactly right so Kyle when I was
28 years old
we had lost everything we'd filed
bankruptcy
because of my responsibility because I
borrowed too much money
got into a bunch of debt I'm doing flip
this house before chip and Joanna were
there to tell us how
and
um
I had choices at that point my identity
could be
I'm a guy who filed bankruptcy I'm a
failure with money I'm a guy who doesn't
know how to handle money I'm a guy that
believed a bunch of get rich quick lies
and
um failed I'm a business failure
all of those would be accurate
statements about the activity but not
about the person
because I you know I'm not going to
self-identify as a failure those are
things I did that's not the things I did
they're not who I am right and so
instead I said
and I didn't know I was doing it at the
time I learned this from you later but I
accidentally did it I just said um
I'm a guy that made a lot of mistakes
with money and I learned
not to borrow money I'm a guy that never
borrows money
but let's let's you've told your story
let's get in between that you were a guy
that said I'm going to learn about this
the right way yeah I'm gonna learn how
this works a set of skills from the
Bible and from God and your grandmother
common sense I'm a guy that used to
believe academic hogwash about money
that half the culture believes and half
the culture is broke because of it and I
don't have to follow them I'm not a
lemming I'm gonna go learn I'm going to
learn how this really works from rich
people I'm gonna put a stake in the
ground and I learned I don't borrow
money anymore and that's who I am I I
identify as someone who doesn't borrow
money period and I'm I you know how did
I get there well that's an interesting
story but doesn't matter the identity is
I don't borrow money I was a guy who
would mix up everything like you Kyle
and say well I mean if there's money in
the account you know if there's checks
in the checkbook there must be money in
the account I mean it's just like we'll
figure this out because I'm a total
Surplus guy I do I am not a uh uh um
scarcity mindset at all I'm there's
always an abundance there's always a
surplus the glass is always half full
with me I'm I uh for years I tried to
out earn my stupidity because of that
just because I believe it's so we'll go
figure it out we can make some more
money money's always out there we're
just gonna go get some of it and
so and but not having that emergency
fund set to the side
was driving my wife
to distraction I mean into sheer
freaking Terror and so I had to set an
emergency fund aside and say uh for the
sake of my marriage the thing I have
learned is I I am going to pretend like
that money is not there we don't even
touch the emergency fund still if
there's an emergency we just figure it
out and don't touch the emergency fund
we have never touched the emergency fund
in 30 years because we can't touch it
it's not there and if we do Sharon would
be launched into orbit somewhere and
we'd have to pull her back down she if
you get near that emergency fund it
reminds her bankruptcy and the lights
being cut off and the water being cut
off and a little kid with no food and
she remembers all this stuff and she
remembers it very clearly and so we
can't go near that fund and I'm okay
with that I don't even remember it's
there anyway I got to figure it out
because I forgot it so that's what you
do you set this money aside in a
completely separate account attached to
nothing and you forget that it's there
and what does that look like in real
life it looks like this
I am never gonna borrow money again I'm
a guy that will never borrow money I'm
gonna Steward my family's finances along
with my wife
hey Dave we got to get a new car this
thing's ridiculous not happening hey
Dave the air conditioner's been on the
car we don't have any money not buying
it
hey Dave fill in the blank I'm tired I
want to go on vacation yeah so here's
the thing Sharon when we the kids were
this size when we're coming out of the
bankruptcy and we're digging out yeah I
don't know I don't know if I've ever
told us and I'm probably gonna get in
trouble but she would get this blender
with the top off I mean little kids
running around by the end of the day she
spent just taking care of
small people that don't make sense right
and it's just they're just they're just
wild just mule offense animals right
it's just crazy they're feral and so you
come home and she's got that wild look
in her eyes and she's like I need a
vacation I need a vacation I need a
vacation and it became a thing it's like
I need a vacation and we're like well we
don't want any money we're not going on
vacation so but it was just she knew
that and she knew we weren't going but
it was her way of expressing
the the frustration with the day so we
we finally got out we you know cleared
up we got a bunch we're starting to make
some money we'd say to somebody we
bought a house and pay cash for it we're
doing pretty good A couple years later
we bought we pulled a hundred thousand
dollars out and bought this tiny little
Shack of a lake house
and I had this whole thing printed up
with a picture of the lake house on it
and we named the lake house Sharon's
vacation
because she had earned that vacation she
talked about that for so much but you
know it's a matter of saying this stuff
out loud and yet being grown-ups about
it so re-identify with this Kyle
re-identify and say I'm a guy that saves
money I'm not an irresponsible guy I
used to be but I'm not anymore and it's
it's hard getting there I used to be a
lot of things but I'm not anymore that's
right thank God
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
the phone number is
888-825-5225 this is the Ramsey Show
Stephen is with us Stephen is in
Cleveland Ohio hi Stephen welcome to the
show
hi Dave how are you doing today sir
great man what's up
yeah so here's the deal for myself
um currently I make uh 61 000 a year
um I am our laser bricks down about 29
an hour
um I have a great opportunity to move
jobs in the same industry and go to
salary and with a salary change up to 88
000 a year
so somebody seemed like a no-brainer for
some people but some of the issues with
myself are the following
um so the job is somewhere else and we
would have to sell our house
um the part of that would be we've only
lived in our house for coming up on a
year
and so that's one issue the other issue
um we would have to move in with our
mother-in-law for at least six months to
a year until we either found something
to rent or to buy
and then really the biggest thing is it
doesn't take six months to find
something to rent
yeah I mean you're right there
absolutely absolutely so we can take the
Mother-in-law thing as mandatory off the
table yeah that's Shenanigans dude it's
an option but it's not mandatory that's
you coming up with reasons to not do
this
yeah well so
um luckily I like my mother-in-law
unlike some people so she's great um
that's okay I like mine but I want to
live in with her
I understand I understand all right so
what where is the other job
so the other job would be in West
Virginia
okay so how long have you lived in
Cleveland
um we lived in Cleveland for two years
bought our house last September rented
before that and you moved from where
another house almost a year where did
you move um yeah the town where we would
be going back to oh so you're going back
home so to speak correct yes and is that
what you want to do forget the money
right let's say you can make 88 000
there or you can make 88 000 in
Cleveland where would you live
it would be with family
um I was also going to say as as well um
we don't have any relatives in Cleveland
it was mostly to move
um to okay so you get to move where you
want to move back home near family and
make more money what is the question Bye
Felicia
I know I know and I I know and I I guess
I I'm probably the one that sounds dumb
on my end but there's like there's so
much emotional attachment I should add
my wife and I just welcomed a baby girl
I'll be six months in two weeks
um send so many firsts in our first home
you know bringing her home finding out
you know that she's going to be a girl
all those things dude it's a box of
sticks with a roof on it man go be with
your family
like for real and it'll it'll be hard
for a year it will be hard for about a
minute and a half we go home man sure
sure and I guess okay so I guess that
portion answered my second portion would
be
um with the money that we would profit
from our house so luckily I'm pretty
handy as well as my father-in-law we did
some work on our house
um we bought it for um 168's currently
payoff is 155.
um we just had it appraised for 2 30
with the improvements that we made
um hopefully selling it for more than
that with the market currently so
pocketing around fifty thousand
so my question is I with that money how
much should I throw toward the debt if
not all of it and how much should I save
how much debt do you have
um so I currently have around fourteen
thousand dollars in credit card debt
um I have run 6 000 in medical bills
um and that's really it besides the
house
um I'm luckily when is the one year when
did you actually close on the home to
own it
okay you do not close before September
22nd of 23 because you will be texted
ordinary income versus long-term capital
gains
okay if you own the house one year if
you own it one year you get taxed on one
time one year Capital
um long-term capital gains if you're
only two years you have no taxes at all
okay so you don't close even if you put
on the market yet tomorrow you don't
close before September 22nd yeah I doubt
you would you probably wouldn't anyway
yeah but just make sure okay then you're
going to have a tax of 15 of your gain
your gain is this what you sell it for
minus what you paid for it
minus sales expenses
minus any big Capital Improvements that
you and your father-in-law did to the
house name me something big you did to
the house
uh we replaced the back deck okay the
deck cost
labor included
um well if we were just so we did have
somebody come out and just give us a
quote it was going to be around nine
thousand dollars okay nine thousand
dollars comes off of this
okay okay because you had you know you
got to pay labor to fix the debt all
right and so stuff like that so you're
not going to have much gain because you
got expenses
minor you got fifty thousand dollar gain
but you've got expenses coming sales
expenses coming off of that you're gonna
have some realtor fees some other stuff
that's going to be easily ten fifteen
thousand bucks you're gonna have this
other ten thousand dollars for the deck
so you're not gonna have a very big gain
but your whatever the gain is you're
going to be taxed at 15 of the gain so
if the gain is twenty thousand dollars
that's three thousand dollars taxes
understood okay okay you gotta set that
aside then we'll pay all of these pay
these twenty thousand dollars worth of
uh
Dad off and then when you move you
probably are going to rent for a little
while and save up some money and buy a
house that's what I would do
and you're going back to an area that
you know really well why do you why have
you locked yourself into your
mother-in-law's house for six months
um it's mostly I we don't want to make
any type of
um very quick decisions as to what kind
of house we're going to buy next
just go go get your rental house for six
months
yep and then pile up some cash and you
know have your baby in your own home
with your own wife and your own
independent little nuclear family there
let your mother-in-law come visit you
yeah that's what they're supposed to do
and then they can go home
and then you can let them go home and
all of that you can take your baby with
you so yeah they can actually babysit at
their home that's very nice okay I'm
liking this even better now grandparents
like it too by the way I'll be taking
I'll be taking care of one of mine
tonight so there you go the grandkid
that is so uh yeah that none of them
living with me though I'm just saying
all right so um anyway yeah that's what
I would do man I I so I don't think
there's any the only negative side of
the equation was memories of the home
he's lived in for less than one year
was that the only negative yeah I think
again it's a similar conversation we had
with an earlier caller I think there is
something about I'm an hourly guy that's
kind of who I am I fix stuff
hey here's a salary job for 88 000 and
those are jobs that other guys get okay
and now I'm gonna be a suit I'm gonna be
an indoor guy and that's a different
that's a that's a different mental shift
and that's right and you're you know and
your cousin who isn't is going to be
living near you because you're moving
back near him that's right and you're
going to have more money than your
parents you're gonna it's just gonna be
a different ball game and that's it's
it's it's wise to get in front of that
starting line and say is this the right
the right trajectory and that's why you
call people and say hey I can't see this
clearly what do you think and Dave and I
are telling you move to Virginia enjoy
your time kind of a no-brainer yeah go
for it man yeah we're proud of you yeah
it's um but let's let's keep this family
stuff real
clean clear now clear lines clear lines
it's just good for everybody it's good
for relationships it's good for money
so you're debt free you're living in a
rental for six months you've got some
money not a bunch but you got some money
in an account you're gonna be adding to
that and next spring you're looking for
a place
I remember when Sheila and I moved from
our first house that we ever bought I
remember it was so nostalgic and I drove
by a couple years ago just to like as a
drive down memory lane and I was just
remember going ugh and I finally had
gotten pad man it's just a box you're
such a snob it's a box your snap nah man
you're just too good for that
neighborhood now oh no that
neighborhood's way way better than than
I am way better that's what I went back
and I went either this place went down
or my tastes have changed probably both
actually in this case it was both yeah
it's gone down and my tastes have
changed yeah yeah so I'm just not
straight up snuff yeah I I've adjusted
my expectations in life there you go
well it's going to clip well on social
media ah you know I worry about that I
lay awake at work Twitter bothers I just
I wonder about I worry about what
Twitter thinks about me it's my my
biggest fear John well now that you're a
tick tock sensation man no there's that
that's see there so that's why I don't
care about Twitter this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
thank you foreign
our scripture of the day Colossians 3 23
and whatever you do do it hardly as to
the Lord and not to men
Jordan Peterson says pursue what is
Meaningful not what is expedient
and they're seldom the same thing John
they're almost never the Never
see what is mean it's very seldom that
something that is Meaningful is also
expedient
they just don't usually line up Kelly is
with us Kelly's in Nashville hi Kelly
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi thank you for taking my call today
sure what's up
um so about three years ago right at the
start of covid we were blessed to be
able to come out and do our debt-free
screen with you and we paid off
everything minus our home and we went
back to California and then we said you
know what we're gonna do this the whole
shebang and we sold our home in
California moved out here to Tennessee
and we paid off our mortgage bought a
home out here so we are physically
completely debt free thankful you know
to you and of course my husband who had
to get me on board but um we're very
blessed but now so you pay cash for a
house when you moved yes yes so we
physically have no debt um whatsoever
how's that feel
I still think about it it's very it's
very
very blessed because we have 11 year old
and eight-year-old and we've really I
was the the word the wisdom and the wine
you know and all that and so I were able
to get through but it was good it was
it's nice to be here now in this place
um but we did move our family we I was
my husband and I were born and raised in
California
um it's not a place to raise children
anymore so we came to the the promised
land of Tennessee
um but my question to you and I'm glad I
also have um Mr Delaney there as well
but um my husband was in the same
profession he was a physical therapist
at a practice for 14 years I'm in an
aesthetic sales industry and so we did
the move and I think he's kind of fallen
into a rut we were working for 21 months
to pay off all the debt and then now not
having that goal to work towards anymore
but I think part of him is kind of lost
but he doesn't have that um we moved
from all of our friends and family
trying to you know get that built here
has been a little bit of a struggle and
I think he's kind of hit you know a wall
in his profession and I'm trying to tell
him to quit his profession and to work
at the golf course part-time but he's
having a really hard time until I called
in and spoke to Dave and Dave gave us
the okay that he can quit his job
um this was like I just want to get your
idea on what he could possibly do now in
you know in regards to his thoughts and
feeling like he's still
I had I don't know I still work
full-time I love working
no he didn't quit he's still a physical
therapist here how many hours is he
working
he is working five days a week
um so you know 40 hours a week yeah and
what what is his problem then Kelly
that's not the job man it's not the job
his passion for physical therapy he's
not he's not he's not he's a okay an
incredibly Lonely Man Without a mission
okay without a unified without not
standing shoulder to shoulder with his
wife saying what's next for us
because you crossed that finish line and
you went Wahoo and you went straight
over to the Beer stand and he was like
what's the next workout
yeah and so
you all have to make a decision that we
are going to go away on a retreat just
the two of us and do something we never
thought possible and that is planned for
the future what could be now that we've
done all this hard work and y'all got to
create a new road map quickly
well and I think too I still want to
work full-time I I'm I'm really I'm
really good at what I do I do sales and
technically I feel we could Charlie you
don't have to listen Kelly you don't
have to apologize you don't have to no
no qualify I'm not apology I'm not
apologizing I just want to know if our
numbers are in line where I could
physically get him out of doing what
he's been doing for the last I don't
think he needs to I don't think that I
don't think that's what it is
I think he's lonelier than you can
imagine and the the man he no longer has
something to work towards and he has
nobody around him no no gang his gang's
back in California and he has no goal
the goal's gone he'll be miserable at a
golf course he'd be miserable as a CEO
at HCA downtown he's going to be
miserable wherever he happens to be
okay
and so if you all got on the same page
and you all said okay we want to have
this kind of house we want to have this
kind of vacation we want to save this
kind of money for our kids college and
you know started a plan and you slowed
down now that you've been sprinting and
y'all started inviting people over once
a week to your house intentionally
leaving out a basket of laundry just so
you can practice getting over that
and then you do that for six months and
then he comes to you and you'll have a
couple of friends and he goes out to
have nachos and drinks with him and says
hey guys I think I'm gonna quit my job
now we can have that conversation but
you would be running from one
one hollow moment to another wherever he
goes he's gonna show up there and if he
is aimless and he is lonely he's going
to show up there too so it changes from
um
I'll tell you a bookkeep you can pick up
is um Bob Beaufort wrote a book years
ago called half time
and it's not unusual for males in
particular men to uh spend the first
half of their life in acquisition
the acquiring of things and the second
half of their life in search of
significance
and that's the stage that we're shifting
through here that maybe step seven has
pushed that forward regardless of his
age and so
um you know I went through that really
early because I went broken because I
started this that I moved immediately
where I didn't care about acquisition I
cared about significance and doing what
I do helping people was a lot more
important to me than piling up a pile of
stuff and I went through it about 24
months ago that's why I'm so passionate
about it because I just went through
this yeah so making that shift
intentionally now what some what it
sounds like for some people is they stay
at work
and they say my new goal is
um I've got a heart for fill in the
blank I've got a heart for uh adoption
for foster kids being adopted I've got a
friend that's all over that okay and um
so I'm going to I I'm going to build a
thing where we can pay for other people
to do adoptions and I'm going to build a
pile of money to do that and I'm going
to set that goal very clearly and I'm
going to throw money at it until the
pile is that big and then we're going to
do that and or I'm going to build a a a
home for unwed mothers or I'm going to I
don't care what it is but something it's
probably something that means something
in his life history or something that he
cares about but I'm going to do this
thing for The Unborn I'm going to do
this thing for Hungry children I'm going
to do you know I'm going to be Dolly
Parton and I'm gonna print books and
give them to every child in Tennessee
every month and that's one of the things
she's done obvious initially and so uh
and she comes out of the hills of East
Tennessee where literacy was a problem
it's important to read the kids and so
every child in Tennessee gets a book
from Dolly Parton every month some
fabulously large foundations but I mean
way to go Miss Dolly she's incredible
she's an institution but I mean you can
do all kinds but that so the goal
doesn't have to be acquisition anymore
it could be generosity right there's
another great book need a second clear
goal second Mountain by David Brooks but
here where I think men make this mistake
is they go off by themselves to come up
with this new goal I think this is a
moment when y'all sit down and dream
together oh yeah yeah yeah yeah and do
that together and it might and it might
not come the first time you get you know
the first weekend away the first weekend
we might just be a huge exhale we did it
yeah let's just put a stick in the
ground we celebrate yeah but um yeah you
need something to aim at and then you
can make a decision if the job is really
the problem and you need people in
community in your life and then you can
make a decision if the job is the
problem because I'm not sure it is I'm
not sure it is it was very fulfilling
for a lot of years right and suddenly
it's horrible right yeah that that's
suspect and if and again I want everyone
hearing me to say this like if he quits
his job
and he works part-time at a golf course
he'll feel some relief instantaneously
and then one day he'll be washing his
hands in that bathroom and he'll look up
and see himself in the mirror and
realize he went with him that same guy
with no friends that same guy that
doesn't have a plan with his wife he's
just making 14 of his other salary and
he's dug himself a hole because he
jumped off the ship he jumped off the
roller coaster and so man let's get
together and dream dream dream and sit
down and hey like in my case my wife and
I sat down and had this conversation
several years ago and I said I don't see
myself
in a university saying long term I'll
begin to get another and start training
if into some other field great it took
several years it took five years to get
there but we had a plan together that we
mapped out together and we ended up here
right so whatever that happens to be
don't jump off the ship just yet I don't
think this is one is the job that puts
us out of the Ramsey showing the books
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
foreign
if you like what you heard in this
episode and want to know more about
getting started on the Ramsay baby steps
go to ramseysolutions.com and click on
the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation that's
ramsesolutions.com and click get started
[Music]